hi i'm ryan right recently my father he
passed away and i wanted to do a video
for him because there's two things this
man definitely gave me one is the love
for movies that's why i have a movie
critic now see the correlation and the
other one is he loved to make people
laugh he really enjoyed doing that an
awful lot he was a funny man sometimes
and embarrassing that but overall he's a
pretty funny guy today i want to just
talk about the things that made me laugh
about my dad the things that made
everyone laugh you know and in school
people would always be like dude ryan
right here dad is so is so funny so
things that would embarrass the heck out
of good cuz he certainly everyone's
embarrassed by their parents but my dad
now he certainly had things that were
definitely unique he parked outside
waiting for me for the you know for me
to get out of school and his foot his
bare foot would just be dangling out the
window people walk by and just see my
dad's foot just dangling out the window
he didn't care and then a did the other
thing too I know what he did all these
things you know and but it he had his
reason to like this it's still like you
could children just calmed it down a
little bit um he would stretch in public
everywhere we went it was stretch he was
a it was a good stretcher he was
flexible out of nowhere I don't know he
literally and today yummy I'm in a suit
but with pjs on because that is how I
imagined my father might film this video
for some reason everywhere we went it
could be just imagine anywhere anywhere
you want to imagine the most
embarrassing place to just be kicking
your legs up and down back and forth
trying to kick your foot to the ceiling
inside of the lobby of an olive garden
and it can be pretty freaking
embarrassing here's all those dads who
told the same jokes for like your entire
life basically when you even do it it
was cool is that no matter how many
times you
it was like the first time he said it he
would light up all the time it was like
this radiant joyous smile is like a
little boy so he told me a joke Ashok's
a little inappropriate it's not rated
aurash but it's like Pete Pete you know
pg-13 but almost rated R uh uh this joke
it's worked since I first heard it I
think it told it to me unlike my 10th
birthday or something like that what she
shouldn't have done but he told it to me
anyway and the joke has worked since and
it's gonna get you right now if you
haven't heard it here we go how did
Captain Hook die he wiped his ass with
the wrong hand ha ha yeah you're
laughing I can tell you're laughing
there's this joke that my grandfather
apparently told my grandfather and my
dad they weren't a lot of people know
that they didn't have the best
relationship but what's cool is that
regardless there are things after my
grandfather died that my dad really
enjoyed about which was some of the
jokes that he left behind and I think I
feel like it's a tradition for me to
pass it along so here's another one
there's this guy who worked at a morgue
and his job was to clean up all the dead
bodies so one day he's cleaning up the
morgue and then suddenly there's a cork
inside of a guy's butthole his anus
that's where it is and then he he pulls
out the corec the morgue I cuz that's
what this job is to do stuff like that
he didn't do it out of you know joy he
did it because he's required to so he
pulls out and suddenly here he hears
you're my sunshine my lovely sunshine
you make me happy and then he puts the
cork back in and the music stops say it
does it again you are my sunshine my own
puts it back in music stops so what he
does this he calls up his boss wakes up
his boss it's like four in the morning
and no one likes being woken up at 4am
he's like what what do you want he's
like boss you got to hear this he puts
the phone up to the guys butthole he
takes the cork out and the boss years
you are my sunshine my only sunshine and
the boss says you woke me up at four in
the more
to listen to some [ __ ] saying you are
my sunshine Finn but one thing I really
enjoyed about my father was his hair he
had an interesting set of hair you know
those people who have like long hair but
it's their balding at the same time and
it's a weird look I I think you should
just shave it you know bryan cranston
breaking bad you could learn a few
things his hair was like a bunch of
weird curls everywhere Anna and I have
those curls you see this here right now
this hair I work on because of the genes
my father gave me those genetics make my
hair look like a giant bush he was also
a fan of Mel gifts another way the good
Mel Gibson not the not a bad Mel Gibson
if there's one thing my parents have in
common it's they both really love Mel
Gibson there's nothing that could tear
them apart when it came to that topic I
think my mom still has even with mel
gibson's bad image now she still loves
the old Mel Gibson and her whole office
is blasted with pictures of Mel Gibson
and I think my father greatly approved
of this for some reason when I was going
in elementary school he would call my
school for the weirdest things these
things were things you don't have to
call about they can wait but no my dad
gets weirdly impatient about certain
things one time I gotta call the saying
that your dad is on the line in the
office downstairs you got to take it and
it was like 10 a.m. or something like
that was like oh my gosh what happened I
pick up the phone and then he goes Ryan
right where are the avocado that's a
true story that really accepted the Rye
Rye part what's my real identity my dad
loved celebrities the way I love Ryan
Gosling is the way my dad loved
celebrities in general and you know if
you recognize someone even if he wasn't
a big fat he would do whatever it took
to get in front of that person one time
we were driving on an
down Ventura Boulevard outcomes walking
out of a starbucks Teri Hatcher and what
he does with the whole family in the car
he pulls the car over and then he gets
out of the car tells me to come with him
for some reason so I I go with him and
he's rooms like walking reason running
but he's a fast walker and he was
walking so fast shouting Terry Terry
yeah I just I'm speechless did you would
do that she turned around they had a
great conversation it is awesome I
cannot say my dad really loved me
growing up but there's there's just one
thing he didn't an awful lot that was
just a little neglectful whenever we
would go anywhere yet say we were
shopping at Whole Foods that was
interesting experience and going to
whole foods you know cuz whole foods is
expensive and he knew that but he still
went and complained every time you
bought stuff one day we were just
walking around whole foods and the
ability this man has to eat one day just
leave your site and he can't outrun he
cannot run due to health issues but
surprisingly he would vanish the second
you turned around he was the fastest
walker you've ever seen you you would
literally have to go looking through
stores to find this guy stores stores
but Evan sometimes lie and these are
weird lies I don't know how people
believe these lies you know like it for
example a these are a consistent lives
that he would do whenever he'd meet
someone and he asked what race they are
no matter what race they work he would
say I'm that race to you even do it
clear to the clever you know you would
like what one literally one time there
was an african-american woman in Las
Vegas with us which wasn't with us G she
just really they were just better that
day I don't know I honestly think he
asked her what her ethnicity once but
anyway he and one point he managed to
interject oh my grandfather was half
black to you which was just not true now
that I know he can't get arrested for
this there was one thing it was great at
Peter hopping there's anything I could
do with this guy you taught me how to
feed her huh it was like a spy when it
came to that stuff one time we saw five
movies in one day
for anyone who knew my dad it was he was
someone who would he blame caught
weirdly for he was like Bruce Almighty
if you've ever met him I'm sure at one
point he said something along the lines
of I don't know God just doesn't like me
you know that that was that was a common
one though that was a common one and it
was weird you blame God for for weird
things things that oh well we got want
to get involved with that Judy said to
me when he called me at the school he
said God moved the avocados this guy
literally thought whatever something bad
happened God was at play here and
sometimes you have to argue in my down
when he came to this God stuff because
there was just no reasoning sometimes no
logical reasoning a guy who cut him off
on the road is I who a God did what who
was god there he there was a man driving
the vehicle who I don't think was God in
the car driving the vehicle at the time
when he was wait when he was late he
thought it was God's laws my dad would
wake up late then he would procrastinate
and do a lot of that for some reason
when he has to be somewhere at three and
he was leaving at 258 he thought God had
something to do with him being late
don't get me wrong and I did love God
that's why he felt so strongly about
some stuff I doubt we did this weird
thing when he would talk to people uh in
order to get to know them he would he
would play this game that I like to call
guess the race if he wanted to strike up
a conversation with someone he couldn't
use his surroundings like oh are you
reaching for the avocados to you be like
oh are you are you Chinese for you are
you Puerto Rican and then depending on
what the race was my dad had a sentence
in that language prepared to say that to
them when he guess someone was Mexican
he would say meanie mosaic and even when
the other person spoke perfectly good
English it was probably raised in
America he would still try speaking into
the language do that one thing I love
you Willa know about my dad he was
actually a quarter a real hoarder have
you seen the show hoarders yeah that is
it wasn't as scary as that sure makes it
out to be
but it is it was a hoarders own this guy
he loved his trash trash I guess it was
something special to the guy my father
may be the first person to get banned
from frys electronics if you don't know
it's an electronic store has nothing to
do a french fries if you go there think
you know I'm gonna get a great burger
and shake and fries today you would be
very disappointed my dad he was a little
bit of a con artist a slight con artist
you know nothing nothing that we're
gonna go to prison for but he's a slick
on artist he would buy dvds for for
cheap and then go to a store that sold
that DVD but was more money and he
returned it there to get money so he
would probably earn like three dollars a
DVD I never think there probably weren't
fishing ways to earn more money but
anyway fri is found out about him but
fries didn't know was that there's a lot
more stores out there that lost a lot of
money like Circuit City I almost said I
hope him no Gibson are happy in heaven
but I forgot Mel Gibson's not dead but
what Mel Gibson does die that will
happen yo Mel Gibson will be miles away
my dad will be chasing it down going no
no I'm a producer great thing about
living with a hoarder is um you could
sleep anywhere you could practically go
to the bathroom anywhere I all I have to
do to sleep is you just find a flat
surface and you can rest there it was
awesome you know every guy usually has
you know like oh he likes brunettes oh
he likes blondes my mom my dad like
Asian people Asian people not just asian
woman people there is a fascination with
Japanese people for some reason for some
reason he went to Japan and studied
there in time for four years how to
speak English to people which is weird
because my dad can't even say the word
millennium in fact he can't see a lot of
things when it came to people's names
wasn't very good at it my cousin and her
name is jessica 4 for 21 years he called
her jennifer and he never doubted
himself it was always best when he got a
celebrity's name wrong my brother
certainly got that from him let me tell
you something bout my brother one time
Denzel Washington was at the st. Charles
Festival and I didn't know Denzel
Washington was is I was only four years
old and my brother said
hey why don't you go up to him and ask
hey were you the guy in die hard he's
guys don't know the guy died or was he
was a dad on family matters and honestly
the eights is but they look nothing
alike especially due to the weight
difference so I went up to Denzel
Washington and I said are you the guy
from die hard and he went no I'm not the
guy from God and he just played it cool
well a bunch of other six year old kids
apparently new denzel washington woof I
don't know what Denzel Washington movie
they've seen for six-year-olds to
appreciate that guy remember the titans
had not come out yet my dad had some
funny inconsiderate manners sometimes
there were so many times where I be up
late at night watching conan o'brien
like one in the morning and then he was
just without asking uh open the DVD
player blah peruvian and just change the
channel no hey I'm gonna switch this on
you buddy just let's watch dog day
afternoon all the sudden and the other
thing about that too was uh we lived in
a home where wherever you were even here
the television he loved blast the TV you
know they st. men like to blast it might
my dad would we've had neighbors upset
because of how loud the surround sound
is you could drive past my neighborhood
going 65 miles per hour and you will
hear gunshots from a movie like Wild
West that's right he's one of the few
people that really enjoyed that and I
enjoyed it too something we had in
common there's one thing we had in
common it was that we really loved
movies well there's nothing to talk
about we always had the ability to just
converse it out films and that's why I
loved talking about movies today let me
get straight to the point here all i
gotta say my dad got it right
you